welcome to saw's talks money on
valuetainment i'm your host adam sosnick
and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode
we're going to be breaking down how your
money
should flow let's talk money
so we're going to be talking about how
your money should flow
like you've heard the term cash flow
before what does that actually mean
basically it means
money doesn't like to stay stagnant
money doesn't just to like to sit around
and do nothing money likes to move
money likes to flow so what you can see
behind me
is a flow chart of how your money
should flow so it's actually going to be
pretty interactive episode
i'm going to be writing on the board
there's going to be some arrows going
left going right
so pay attention and at the end of this
episode we're going to be giving you a
free pdf that you could use
to make sure that your money is flowing
in the right direction
so with that said let's get right in to
how your money should flow all right so
let's start at the top and at the top of
the chart
you got income this is your career this
is your work this is your job this is
your side hustle this is how you make
that money so this
is where everything starts right so this
is where
the majority of your focus should be at
least initially
making that money focusing
on income income income
income it's all about making that money
if you're not making that money you have
no cash flow
so that's where everything starts with
income now speaking about income what is
the median
income in america today well we've
covered this before but i'll break it
down again the median
household income in america today is 63
000 and the median income for a
full-time worker
is just above 48 000 so what does that
basically mean
most americans are pulling in between
four and five
thousand dollars a month varying on your
job your career your state
and all that so like i said it all
starts with income
and now you've entered the game of
capitalism and you've made that money
now what do you do with your money let's
get into the flow chart so now
once you start to make income where does
your money go from there
well step one is it goes right into your
checking account your checking account
is the hub of your money it's the
central
nervous system of your money so boom
your money's in your checking account
now most people what do they do they get
their money they get time to pay bills
not so fast step one is pay
yourself first so it sits your checking
account number
one it should go right to your savings
account you've heard that before
pay yourself first what does that
actually mean that means before you pay
rent
before you pay bills before you pay
credit cards before you pay creditors
you know who you need to pay first
well you need to pay yourself first boom
so let's talk about savings and then
we'll get into the rest of the flow
chart
so speaking of savings let's talk about
saving that money
the current savings rate in america
today is 7.6 percent meaning if you make
a thousand
bucks you're putting seventy dollars
sixty cents in your pocket what your
goal
should be is to save ten percent so if
you make a thousand bucks
boom a hundred bucks go right into your
wallet you you got to pay yourself
first so let's talk about savings when
you talk about goals and accounts so
what is the accounts and what are the
goals
now we talk about accounts obviously
we're talking about going from your
checking to your savings what's the
point here
emergency fund rainy day fund a cushion
right so
god forbid something happens to your
life you're not going back into your
checking
going back into debt you have savings so
this is can be
obviously in a savings account in a cd
money market account
the point is that you're stacking cash
stacking
cash now when you talk about goals these
are short
term goals for the next six to 12 months
this is where savings
should be right six to 12 months the
next one to two years and then thinking
a little bit longer out
the next three to five years maybe you
want to buy a house maybe you want to
put a down payment on a property
this is savings this is savings this is
savings
save that money your goal if you're
going to be paying yourself first before
you get to the rest of this stuff
is to save ten thousand dollars
now talking about some crazy stats in
america
seventy eight percent of americans are
living paycheck to paycheck
okay seventy eight percent twenty 25
have no savings at all straight up
nothing in the bank nothing zero
40 percent don't have 400 bucks to cover
an emergency flat tire
sorry got to go back into debt don't
have 400 bucks 69 percent of americans
don't have a thousand dollars in savings
but here's the catch here's the saddest
part of this
the average american average american i
know if you're watching this and you're
you're this far
into this episode you're far beyond
average but the average american will
make between
one and two million dollars in their
lifetime so don't tell me that you're
not making that much money
it's that the fact that you're spending
that money so your goal here
savings short term stack cash save that
money
ten thousand dollars that's your goal
okay so that's savings now that's just
one portion of this flowchart there's
two other portions that we're going to
cover
obviously your bills we're going to get
to that and investments that's where
we're going to end up here
so you got your checking account that's
the hub the next step is
you got some bills to pay baby
everybody's got bills
to pay everybody watching this has the
same big
three expenses what are these big three
expenses that we're talking about
well housing transportation and food and
beverage
where you live how you get around and
what you eat and drink so after your big
three expenses that's where
everybody differs everybody has
different expenditures and
things that they are spending their
money on you got insurance you got cell
phone you got clothing
this is personal and discretionary
spending maybe you're going on vacation
maybe you like to party maybe you like
to drink maybe you like to have fun
maybe you like to go to games maybe you
like to play video games maybe you like
sports
all different types of personal and
discretionary spending so this is where
bills come in this is what i would call
a spender's mentality obviously everyone
has the same
big three expenses after that you're
just spending money on the lifestyle
you want cool lifestyle everybody wants
the same lifestyle
we're going to get back to lifestyle in
a second so the last part of this is
debt obviously people
have debt you got credit card debt you
got student loan debt you got car loan
payments
this is all coming after you pay
yourself first
so those are your bills those are your
expenses and just so you know
this right here my friends is 80
of your income so i'm not saying you
can't spend money i'm not saying you
can't
live the life you want that's not what
i'm saying at all i'm saying you have 80
of your income to spend on what you want
to do with your life
so we just covered that 10 of your money
should go to your savings right
80 can go to your bills go to your
expenses now there's 10 percent left
where should that other 10 go well right
here my friends this goes to
investments so now we have a flow chart
going in we got money coming in checking
it's going to savings it's going to
bills and you got investments so now
let's break down investments so with
investments you actually have
two different options right so you have
money that comes from your checking
that goes right into your investments
accounts this is what is known as
after tax dollars so something like a
roth ira one of the best
investment accounts you can possibly
fathom is a roth ira
i encourage you to look into it you can
put in about 6 000
a year depending on your age so this is
after tax dollars that goes right from
your checking
right into investments now you might be
saying what about pre-tax
what about pre-tax well that's where it
comes right from your income
right into a 401k account right into
your investments so if you have a 401k
or if you have not signed up for a 401k
at work
you need to look into that and
especially you need to look into a match
so that comes from your income speaking
of income something that i didn't cover
at the beginning
we all know that this is take home pay
income
now what is gross pay versus net pay
let's cover that when your money hits
your income
there's a couple of things that come out
first well namely
taxes we all know about taxes so if you
make 50 grand a year
that really means you make closer to 40
000 a year
that's taxes my friend what else comes
out of your paycheck
social security tax medicare tax and
maybe some people
have health insurance coming out of
their paycheck before it hits
your checking account cool cool cool we
got that now let's get on to investments
so we talked about saving is short term
well investments
is long term so speaking of investments
the type of accounts we just discussed
401k
iras roth iras these are just very
vanilla
retirement accounts what's within
these accounts well obviously you have
stocks bonds mutual funds
index funds etfs target date funds
you can invest in different types of
commodities i know people out there love
their crypto
this is all investing and just keep in
mind investing
long term growth we're not talking about
day trading here
day trading short term you're in you're
out that's not what i encourage
i encourage long-term investing talking
about long-term investing
what are your goals with this there's
goals within the next five to ten years
wealth accumulation playing the stock
market playing the real estate game
having your assets appreciate you have
goals for the next
10 to 20 years maybe this is a college
savings account for your kids
maybe this is wealth accumulation all
that fun stuff in the market
and then obviously you have super long
term the next 20 30 40 years down the
road
when you're talking about 401ks and iras
and talking about long-term investments
so that's long-term
investing for retirement speaking of
retirement a couple quick facts for you
number one the median retirement balance
in america today
is 60 000 so what does that mean for you
they say that the average american will
need between one
and two million dollars to retire
comfortably so if you're sitting at 60
and you need a million dollars to retire
comfortably you got a lot of work to do
so speaking of work to do only 55
percent of americans
are actually investing now if you didn't
know that a 401k
ira these types of retirement accounts
is considered investing
well now you know so what i would love
to see is a way higher number of
americans
investing i would love to see 80 90
freaking 100 percent of americans
investing in the stock market that is
how you build long
term wealth speaking of long term it's
all about
retirement and in my opinion retirement
is an antiquated term nobody successful
just retires
and does nothing so i have a different
term for you to wrap your head around
when it comes to retirement
what is that term that term is chilling
when you are chilling is when you own
your time
when you're chilling you can do what you
want to do
with your free time so let me ask you if
you were chilling
with money you've done this whole flow
chart you've put the money in your
checking account
you've saved you paid your bills you've
invested you've done everything here's
my question for you
what would you do with your free time
answer that think about it have you even
found out what your why is
so i'll give you the most common
responses when i ask people
that question what they're chilling is
while you're thinking about it i'm gonna
let you know
so number one people would love to
travel obviously during covert right now
people aren't traveling but when this
thing is all said and done
people will start traveling again i
think they're already starting to do
that so number one people would love to
travel
number two if you had all the free time
in the world all the money in the world
what else would you do you would pursue
your passion something that you're super
passionate about whether that's
photography whether that's stand-up
comedy
whether that's writing whether that's
playing music whatever it is you'll have
time
to pursue your passion and what's number
three
the good people out there would love to
donate their time and give back
to causes they care about feeding the
homeless helping the youth
helping disadvantaged families helping
cure cancer
donating your time to causes you care
about this is what most people would do
with their free time
and the last thing is obviously doing
all this to leave
a legacy so here's the deal what's the
point of doing
all this we got arrows coming in coming
out coming left coming right
it's going to your checking you're
saving you're investing you're paying
your bills
what's the point of doing all this stuff
it's to get
to whatever you're chilling is so i
asked you earlier what's your chilling
i'd love to hear
what you're chilling is in the comments
below so that's it that's the end of
this episode
if you enjoyed this there's a free pdf
in the description
below and if you have not seen my
episode on the difference between saving
and
investing that's right here and if you
have not seen my video on how
to win the money game how to get to
chillin
that's right here and if you have not
subscribed to valuetainment economics
please do so below and smash that like
button
if you enjoyed this video and as always
save that money oh we talk is